ich habe mir vor kurzem neue schuhe
gekauft und heute rede ich mit menschen
darüber wie viel geld sie für ihre
schuhe ausgegeben haben los geht's wie
viel haben die schuhe die du trägst
gekostet 30 euro die schuhe haben 55
euro gekostet 59 euro 90 20 euro ich
denke ich glaube so 55 euro warum meine
schuhe die haben so ich glaube 80
ich glaube ich glaube 50 euro ich trage
36 das heißt es ist eine kindergröße
dementsprechend ist es billiger und ich
denke es war ein 56 euro oder so was
welche schuhe trägst du am nächsten
welche spuren hat mich überzeugt am
tiefsten jesuslatschen 60 euro 60 eur 70
euro und was sind die teuerste schuhe
die du hier gekauft hast 300 euro die
teuersten schuhe haben 160 euro meine
ich gekostet das an leder schuhe keine
sportschuhe eine teure schuhe
es sind ein paar lederschuhe für 240 d
mark noch ja ja ich erinnere mich
das ist mein teuerster schuh 130
reduziert 250 gallien italienische
handgemacht 250 die teuersten waren um
die 350 500 euro was waren das für
schulen die habe ich selber haben
gefertigt weil ich als schuster gerettet
habe ich glaube 120 euro 80 euro ja ich
glaube um die 100 also nicht so teuer
was waren das für schuhe lederstiefel
muss das gewesen sein
und was ist eine erfahrung lohnt es sich
teure schuhe zu kaufen auf jeden fall
teure schuhe sind es wert gekauft werden
weil man sie einfach länger tragen kann
sie sehen besser außen sind angenehme am
fuß auf jeden fall
natürlich lohnt sich das weil die halt
man neben lang die bringe ich zum
schuhmacher der repariert die ist das
leder alles gut die habe ich wirklich
bis ich sterbe
na ja also ich lege wert darauf dass ist
leder ist so kein kunststoff
naja wenn ich mehr geld hätte würde ich
auch bestimmt eure schuhe tragen
manchmal ist die qualität von teuren
schulen tatsächlich den preis
entsprechend und dann halten sie länger
nicht zwingend vor allem aktuell sind
glaube ich sehr schlimme schuhe sehr
teuer
glauben sie daran dass die teuren schuhe
auch besser sind
nicht unbedingt eigentlich nicht was
haben die billigsten schuhe gekostet was
du gekauft hast zwei euro die billigsten
die ich gekauft habe 199 3 euro oder 2
euro bei h&m glaube ich schon mal 14 99
oder 1999 ja und wie viele paar schuhe
hast du sehen hier sehr wenige in einem
frau begehbaren schrank waschen so
ähnlich ja also ich denke mal 20 45
ich habe mich ausgerüstet also 44
tierpark nicht viele schon laufschuhe
fußballschuhe und 24 paare ja
ausreichend 160 ein begehbarer schrank
voller schulen das haben die hip hopper
ist wie sehen
die ich regelmäßig trage ich bin in
klamotten fan ich trage gerne ein stück
also ja auch gerne mal keines nur ich
denke ich habe fahre ich trage um die
10.000 ungefähr so 10 ungefähr 7 und
welche art von schulen tragen sie am
liebsten turnschuhe
also es liga die ich aktiv trage nicht
so viel fünf paar oder so und im schrank
viele alte und was haben die teuersten
schuhe gekostet die ehe gekauft haben
antwortet uns in den kommentaren
und falls ihr weiter deutsch lernen
wollt dann empfehlen wir euch die zeit
lang auszuprobieren
dort findet ihr unter anderem ein kabel
trainer mit den 4500 wichtigsten
deutschen wörtern und einen gender
trainer mit dem ihr die artikel zu den
wichtigsten deutschen namen üben könnte
schuss und bis nächste woche
[Musik]